pilote de chasse un métier de rêve et
qui s'apprend à la base aérienne de
tours mais quel est le quotidien de ces
élèves qui plus tard seront engagés sur
des zones de conflit ou encore affectés
à la protection du territoire
nous avons passé une journée avec l'un
d'entre eux
le lieutenant julien à 25 ans originaire
de nice il a fait deux ans de classe
préparatoire avant d'entrer à l'école de
l'air à salon de provence puis la base
aérienne de cognac
comme chaque jour ou presque il doit
s'exercer dans un simulateur mais son
entraînement donc le four on le voit si
on va faire des barrages après le
décollage on va tourner à gauche comme
59 jusqu'à 5 nautiques d'accord
attention à partir des ja pour des
limites à 259 comme dans un vol réel
il assiste au briefing de sa mission
puis entre dans cette machine
elle représente à l'identique le cockpit
d'un alphajet et s'incline également
pour reproduire les mouvements de
l'avion pour l'exercice le moniteur
coupe l'un des réacteurs le moteur droit
je prends plus neuf qu'on fermait plus
jeune elle assure ford se rechargeant
qu'on fait le couple crime l'élève doit
appliquer très rapidement la procédure
et on va s'établir tranquillement son
radio
un ami savoir si on peut râler le pilote
a su manoeuvrer et se poser en urgence à
chaque exercice
le moniteur simule une panne différentes
et juge élèves sur ces réactions des
collages bien gérée après le décollage
donc bonne application des procédures
d'urgence jeu bonne gestion de la
trajectoire remonter ça peut arriver et
c'est pour ça que le simulateur
c'est ça qui est bien c'est que ça ça
prend ça colle au plus proche de la
réalité
on peut pas faire en vol par exemple en
vol on peut pas éteindre un moteur
au décollage je sais c'est un peu on
pourrait le faire mais d'un point de vue
sécurité c'est absolument interdit donc
du coup on le fait aux simulateurs pour
que nous justement on soit bien préparé
que je le redis encore à faire ces
actions réflexe qui peuvent sauver la
vie en fait et après l'exercice virtuel
le vol réel chaque matin a lieu le point
météo en compagnie de tous les élèves et
formateurs
aujourd'hui si elle dégagé le compte à
rebours a commencé
l'élève doit alors préparé son vol le
plus précisément possible et le
présenter à son un script quant au
briefing sécurité et reuters ont fait on
demande
le décollage l'autorisation pour le
décollage et on fera un départ en basse
altitude basse altitude
juste pour le réglage entendu
du vent de travers donc selon elle on
essaie d'utiliser au maximum le
palonnier 100 m coup de frein pense bien
à tout le monde marche
rien n'est laissé au hasard dans le
briefing plan de vol essence embarquée
aéroport de secours
là aussi le moniteur simulera une avarie
soit pas sur les paroles dites de 22h le
faire pilote un avion libyen la
procédure et challans serait fait un
exercice exercice anciens marche de la
pression par rapport la mission par
rapport à la mission ce qui les rend
c'est clair la base de tours et spécial
car c'est un point commun entre tous les
pilotes apprentis comme instructeur tous
sont passés par ici dans des promotions
petit moins d'une dizaine d'élèves
mais aujourd'hui la formation est moins
rude elle s'est standardisée et le monde
de l'armée a changé les gens prêtent un
petit peu plus attention à leur vie à
leur condition de vie personnelle à leur
vie familiale
on a des élèves qui sont un petit peu
plus vieux que ce que nous on pouvait
être à l'époque puisque on a rajouté
plein de phases dont qu'ils arrivent ici
ils ont quatre cinq ans de plus que ce
que nous on avait quand
on arrivait en école et donc les bat on
peut plus demander la même chose à
quelqu'un qui a 30 ans que quelqu'un
qu'on avait 22 ou 23 voilà mais revenons
à notre élève décollage imminent
il faut s'équiper c'est une combinaison
qui est relié au système oxygène de
l'avion et qui permet de comprimer les
jambes et les abdominaux pour empêcher
le sang de descendre si vous voulez
lorsqu'on prend du facteur de charge une
mission ça commence dès le délai bref
fini dès le début du brushing il faut
être concentré et savoir ce qu'on va
faire avec un mécanicien l'élève et le
formateur sont le tour de leur alpha jet
pour vérifier qu'il est prêt à décoller
issu du tour le bloc de frein nos pneus
amortisseurs ses avions à réaction sont
dédiés uniquement à l'apprentissage des
pilotes
il vole jusqu'à 1000 km heure on remet
tout en place les actions italie check
list dans la tête pour que pour qu'on
aille vite et qu'on est que ça marche
bien
bien sûr bien sûr toujours est ce que je
vous disais il est nécessaire ce serait
ce parce que sans ce récit n'en m'a
peut-être comprendrait de mauvaises
habitudes on aurait tendance à faire
n'importe quoi et là avec un petit
stress qui va qui va bien donc ça nous
met dedans
après une ultime vérification à bord
l'équipage se prépare pour une heure
d'exercice les moteurs vont s'allumer
et heureusement été la fréquentation des
prêts
jour-là 09 service devant 0,68
c'est extraordinaire y'a pas d'autres
mots c'est extraordinaire parce que
c'est nous qui avons les commandes c'est
nous qui prenons le contrôle de cette
machine cet avion à réaction et c'est
quelque chose normalement de
l'exceptionnel
grosse remise en question on sait
marcher à prendre à quelqu'un a marché
c'est traduire bas ici c'est exactement
la même chose on sait piloter les avions
de chasse ont fait des missions très
complexe maintenant enseigné les
principes de base de pilotage la gestion
du stress
bah c'est une grosse remise en question
mais c'est tous les jours différents et
c'est fabuleux pas un métier c'est le
plus beau métier que puissent exister
instructeur
physiquement c'est fatigant parce que
l'organisme subi mais pendant le vol
c'est pas ça qui est fatigue le plus
en effet c'est la concentration qui on
demande d'avoir vraiment être tout en
nous ce qu'on appelle être au taquet et
gérer cette pression qui est continuelle
et et pour fournir justement une
émission propres etc chaque seconde
voilà je tu as fais tout à fait tout à
fait et c'est pour ça que je vous disais
tout à l'heure que dure un durant un vol
d'une heure une heure et demie on ne
peut pas se permettre de prendre dix
minutes de plaisir par exemple d'être
dans l'avion et de dire je fais rien non
c'est pas possible
but de ces vols apprendre aux élèves à
s'adapter les préparer à toutes les
situations pour qu'ils réagissent le
plus rapidement possible et rien ne
remplace les changes avec les anciens
pilotes comme le commandant de la base
qui fait part de son expérience voir là
la différence entre les réacteurs
alors ça la différence tu vas l'avoir
tout de suite effectivement la machine
c'est pas la même à tour l'arrivée sur
un avion réaction va compresser le temps
et ils vont se retrouver à devoir
prendre des décisions sur des délais
beaucoup plus court de l'ordre de la
seconde ou de 5 secondes pour faire des
choix et tout ces compressions temporel
va vraiment être très difficile à passer
pour les certains élèves et dont tout
l'enjeu va être d'être ici dans cette
école de les aider en fait à prendre des
décisions rapidement pour pouvoir être
efficace
prendre des décisions rapidement les
élèves qui seront confrontés pendant une
vingtaine d'années
la durée moyenne de leur carrière de
pilote mais avant d'en arriver là le
lieutenant julien doit encore passer
plusieurs mois à tours et réussir toutes
ces missions avec sérieux plusieurs mois
durant lesquels l'élève pilote chassera
son rêve